[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute machen wir einen
leckeren salat rezept und zwar nicht
irgendeinen salat wir machen fakt ist
viele von euch kennen vertuscht bereits
für die dies nicht gleich mal ganz kurz
das ist ein libanesischer gemischter
salat mit einem ganz leckere pressing
aber das besondere das sind diese so
gern orientalischen croutons denn das
sind kleine so libanesische planen brote
gerüstet im ofen ich zeig euch jetzt
aber zuallererst die kompletten zutaten
ich hab die zutaten alle schon sehr fein
geschnittenen wir benötigen tomaten
gurken frühlingszwiebeln petersilie
außerdem rote paprika und radieschen
zitronensaft möhren ganz wichtig ist
auch olivenöl an gewürzen salz frische
minze gerne auch getrocknete ganz
wichtig ist zu mag
außerdem fällt salat oder eisbergsalat
je nachdem was sie da habt und das
allerwichtigste
das ist dieses libanesische fladenbrot
das bekommt ihr in jedem türkischen oder
arabischen supermarkt ich habe meines
von kappadokien
ich glaube es hat mir schon gedacht und
das ist heute der star unseres salat und
damit starten wir auch gleich denn ich
habe ja alles vor geschnippelt und das
geht ganz schnell deswegen starten wir
zuallererst mit dem brot also ihr lieben
ihr könnt natürlich selber entscheiden
wie viele brote jetzt verwendet ist
können auch natürlich je nachdem sein
wie viele bei euch schon hat zuhause
rumliegen wenn man die hart sind
eigentlich auch super für den salat ich
nehme jetzt vier weil ich bin um ehrlich
zu sein so ein kandidat ich es dass auch
vom fernseher wie chips ohne salat für
das so lecker ich mag die mehr als du
jetzt schneiden wir die uns in vierecke
zurecht
[Musik]
so ich habe die brote jetzt auf meinen
backblech gegeben und jetzt geben wir
dann noch olivenöl drauf und verteilt es
gut mit den händen
ich muss dazu sagen es gibt auch viele
leute die frittieren das ist könnt ihr
natürlich machen ist vollkommen euch
überlassen aber ich finde das muss nicht
sein sagte sich das boot so voll mit
fett und so finde ich das einfach viel
knackiger unangenehmer gibt er jetzt wie
gesagt olivenöl drauf und verteilt es
erst mal gut mit den händen
[Musik]
außerdem ist es ganz wichtig dass ihr
die brote jetzt auf dem bug wirklich so
verteilt dass sie möglichst nicht
übereinander liegen damit ihr auch
richtig schön gleichmäßig gebräunt
werden
[Musik]
sobald ihr dann alles gleichmäßig
verteilt haben wir das in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 170 grad für
acht bis zehn minuten aber denkt daran
jeder backofen backt anders deshalb habt
immer ein auge drauf schaut immer so
zwischendurch ob das nicht schon zu
braun ist wo die acht bis zehn minuten
nutzen wir jetzt um den salat zubereiten
ich habe ja schon fleißig alles vor
geschnippelt deswegen gebe ich jetzt
einfach alles in die schüssel und
anschließend setzen wir das ganze
[Musik]
so und jetzt sind alle zutaten verrühren
wir das gut miteinander
schaut mal wie toll die farben aussehen
und jetzt geben wir schon mal das
olivenöl mit hinzu weiter ruhig ein
bisschen vorsichtig wenn man kann
dahinter immer noch was dazu gehen so
mache ich immer also immer schluck für
schluck dazu geben
das öl ist drin jetzt geben wir den
zitronensaft mit hinzu und da könnt ihr
auch selber entscheiden glücklich ein
bisschen zitronige dann macht ruhig ein
bisschen mehr rein
ansonsten könnte das auch reduzieren
nun gebe ich die minze mit hinzu ich
habe jetzt hier frische minze ihr könnt
auch gerne sonst wenn ihr das nicht
findet oder nicht da hat getrocknete
münze nehmen
und jetzt kommen wir zum salz und zum
zug und zum sommer kann ich acht lässt
er offen
okay mein offener grad gekippt ich habe
den gerade noch kurz ausgemacht und
jetzt geht es weiter mit salz kommt der
neben salat dazu gibt es nicht zu sagen
aber zum es zu macht mein lieblings
gewürze moment ich bin total verrückt
danach das nämlich so gesund das ist
essig gewürzt schmeckt so ein bisschen
herten wissen säuerlich und das passt so
gut in salate oder auch in herzhafte
speisen und jetzt wird noch mal alles
gut miteinander verrührt bis wir dann
die orientalischen coupons darauf geben
ich gebe euch jetzt noch einen kleinen
hinweis falls nicht fraglich wie kann
ich den salat auch mittags zu bereiten
und abend zum iftar essen das gibt nicht
so gut weil eben der salat flüssigkeit
verliert und falls ihr dann auch noch
die libanesische bot also diese coupons
drauf gibt dann werden die auch nach
meiner zeit war ich deswegen macht ihn
lieber frisch kurz vorm start aber was
ihr machen könnt ist dass sie halt alles
vorher schnippelt und alles parat auch
bereit das ist kein problem
vorsicht heißt und fertig so dass brot
ist jetzt fertig seit 10 minuten bei mir
rufen rock und genau so muss es aussehen
richtig schön goldbraun und nicht heller
denn erst wenn sie sich richtig schön
gold träumen dann schmecken sie auch
richtig knackig und im grunde genommen
ist der salat schon fertig also verrührt
haben wir ja schon
und genau im grunde ist er da schon
fertig gerne ungerührt gewürzt alles
super jetzt müssen nur noch die boote
drauf ich mache gerne noch lauwarm das
finde ich super lecker ihr könnt aber
auch abkühlen lassen und dann erst drauf
geben
[Musik]
bei uns in der türkei ist fertig jetzt
nicht so bekannt muss ich sagen aber
dafür den arabischen ländern um so mehr
und ich möchte ihnen auch nicht mehr
missen ich mache das ganze jahr über als
beilage oder gerne auch mal so als
zwischenmahlzeit falls ihr das ganze
jetzt nach machen möchtet dann schaut
unten in die infobox da habe ich alle
genauen mengenangaben für euch notiert
verlegt mich gerne wieder über instagram
mit dem hashtag s kitchen mit eurem
wundervollen foto sie schaue ich mir mal
so gerne an
ansonsten wünsche ich euch ganz viel
spaß ihm nachmachen und sagt bis zum
nächsten mal auf die skizzen tschüss
[Musik]
arbeiten ich habe für euch gerade mit
haben sie zusammen fotos abgefilmt hallo
hallo hallo was los mit dir ins
traumland
[Musik]